looking to save on utility costs for
your business or home consider solar
energy these customers are mad I feel
stupid and it's kind of like my own
stupidity I should have did a little
more research we now have 70
000 worth of trash on our roots
so how much is Lee paying
203.50 a month for how long for until
I'm 60 years old so 30 years it's
absolutely false everything they tell
you is alive I don't want others to go
through the same experience that I have
gone through about to see the Dark Side
of solar sails
are literally a scam they say installing
solar panels on your home will save you
money they promise things like big
checks from the governments the federal
government's going to pick up 26 of your
gross total system costs so that isn't a
fun of a check and they're like no
you're gonna get nine thousand dollars
back
any values will go up do solar panels
increase my home's value they say you
can even make money by selling extra
electricity back to the grid so over
producing often diminishes your return
on investment when in reality the only
people benefiting from solar are the
predatory door-to-door salesman Shilling
them and the victims these homeowners
are left in crippling debt that is going
to Shackle them down for the rest of
their lives while the home Solar Company
executives are getting filthy rich
we've seen this with higher education
and now we're seeing it with green
energy with all these cities having
lawsuits filed against home solar
companies stay dangerous and this is the
great solar scam
[Music]
these home solar companies bet on you
not knowing your numbers and not reading
the fine prints that is how they get you
and if you want to make more money then
you gotta know your numbers as well back
when I was making ten dollars an hour I
would literally write down how much I
made and spent every single day onto a
spreadsheet so I knew exactly how much
money was going in and out of my
accounts even though this was super
tedious it forced me to stare at my
numbers every single day and face the
reality that I was broke and it worked
so I can't recommend this enough but if
you want a more automated way to do this
there's this new app called finna.xyz
that would do it for you finna is kind
of like notion but for your finances you
can connect your bank accounts and
credit cards it will import all your
transactions then you can categorize
them and set up rules to automatically
categorize them in the future and most
importantly you can build a custom
dashboard that shows all your numbers
tailored to your needs this is one that
I put that models what I used to do
manually and the best part is that
there's a free tier you can connect an
account and mess around with it to see
if you like it so pause the video and
click the link below to try out our
sponsor fenna.xyz now
selling home solar panels is the perfect
pitch think about it inflation has been
out of control basically things like gas
and groceries are becoming really
expensive and with the threat of
blackouts in California or energy
rationing going on in Europe not being
dependent on the grid seems like a
no-brainer people want to feel safe they
want to save money and they want to feel
in control of their lives and if they
can do that while saving the environment
I mean who wouldn't so here's what you
gotta do if you want to cash in on this
golden opportunity door-to-door solar
sales now door-to-door sales may sound
intimidating and outdated are people
really gonna spend this much money with
a stranger that just rambling knocks on
their door surprisingly yes especially
when you consider all the clever tactics
that we can use when we're face to face
with the mark and the key to
door-to-door solar sales is that you do
not want to look like a typical
door-to-door salesman you want to dress
like a government employee or someone
from the utility company like many of
these sketchy solar companies do that
way you lower their guard down you get
them to not slam the door in your face
and once the door is open you tell them
that you're here to make a very official
assess assessment of your home so they
need to let you into their house and
once you're in their house you pretend
to do a very careful assessment of their
home to see if it's fit for solar hint
the house will always qualify for solar
even if they live in an area without
much Sunshine because remember we're
trying to get a sale here they produce
on rainy days foggy days cloudy days
snowy days I mean it's great and during
this little song and dance you want to
ask to see their energy bills this is
key once you have their energy bills
then you can start working your magic
you want to take whatever they're
typically paying for electricity and
then structure the loan for the solar
panels in a way where it's slightly
cheaper than the current electricity
bill so if your mark is currently paying
200 a month in electricity you
structured the loan in the way so they
only have to pay 150 a month for their
shiny new solar panels but what they
don't realize is that just like how a
sleazy car salesman fudges the numbers
to get your monthly car payment down
sure the monthly payments are lower but
now instead of paying off the car in six
years you're maybe stuck paying off the
loan for 10 to 15 years and you're going
to end up paying way more interest than
before once you have like low monthly
payment in hand that's when you can fake
your surprise and say that wow you
definitely qualify for solar and look we
set it up in a way where you're going to
be paying less than what you're paying
right now for your electricity bill and
the great thing is that says you're
going to be harvesting so much energy
from the Sun your electricity bill is
going to go to near zero or even zero
they will manipulate numbers they will
manipulate prices they will do anything
to get a customer to buy you promised
them that they're going to generate
nearly double the kilowatt hour the
solar panels can actually deliver the
heck you might even generate so much
extra energy that you'll be able to even
make money by selling your extra
electricity back to the grid your
property value is going to go up after
all according to Zillow solar panels do
increase the resale value of your home
by as much as four percent so it must be
true and you'll even get a giant tax
credit from Uncle Sam as a lump sum
check that you'll get in the mail for
going solar and after throwing all these
complicated numbers around you then wow
your customers with big names success
stories like how power home solar
installs solar panels for the Ford
stadium in Detroit the only football
stadium to be powered completely by
solar that is another complete Lie by
the way there are no solar panels in
four stadiums you know he was talking
about power home solar and Ford Field
having these solar panels which I don't
know if they really do but they sold me
on it and what good sales pitch is
complete without some good old scarcity
once your pitch is done you gotta
pressure the home under the sign on the
dotted line today without seeing a
sample contract do not give them a
chance to compare offers and stress that
this is a limited time offer and they
have to act now and with an offer as
irresistible as that they will always
sign and boom you just mean an easy ten
thousand dollars per home there's a
reason why solar sales is known as one
of the best sales jobs out there where
an ambitious salesperson can easily make
a couple million dollars a year in
commission and once the customers do
sign it isn't long before they find out
just how much of a sham this really is
but by then it will already have been
too late
[Music]
thank you
the first way homeowners get worldly
screwed are in the markups like most
solar companies you're actually
reselling panels from another
manufacturer this allows you to jack up
the price by two or even three times the
MSRP Nexus in those Energy savings you
promised them imagine the shock when
customers find out that not only has
their energy bills stay the same but now
they have to pay these loan payments for
the panels on top of their existing
electricity bill and this is no small
amount of money either it was like 300
and something dollars our electricity
bill and the loan is 139 a month this is
a lot more that we ever have paid for
electricity I'm paying 320 for the
system up here and then you add on my
electric bill you're talking close to a
thousand dollars a month and it's really
no surprise why the starting cost of
home solar panels is around 18 to 35
000 and if you want to have extra
electricity at nights or during cloudy
weather when the panels aren't working
then you're gonna need to install a
battery which is another nine thousand
dollars and those conveniently small
monthly payments the salesman was able
to arrange well the interest rate on
most losses eight to nine percents which
if you do the math the average time it
takes to pay off that loan is at least
six to ten years and those already
marked up thirty five thousand dollar
solar panels yeah with that kind of loan
you're gonna end up paying closer to
maybe fifty thousand dollars when you
attack on all the interests and that's
on the low end there are many cases out
there where people get stuck with loads
of up to seventy thousand dollars or
more your bill like last year at this
time was like 103 or something like that
yes and now what is it 105. she's also
strapped with a loan that with interest
adds up to more than seventy thousand
dollars for her power home solar setup
he signed up with solar Titan USA
spending more than seventy one thousand
dollars because he thought it would
reduce his power bill by as much as 90
percent
and that lump sum check you were
promised you would get in the mail yeah
that was a lie too but none of the
customers we talked to got this supposed
check told us there's a 23 000
rebate to spend how we wanted to but
there is no rebate it is true that the
federal government does offer a 26 tax
credit but there's a key phrase there
it's a tax credits which means you need
enough taxable income for it to even
make a difference which also means if
you get a tax refund from the IRS every
year you do not qualify so we spoke to
our CPA to our person that prepares our
taxes for us and and we're like okay so
we're gonna be getting this refund right
and he's like that's not how it works
and we don't make enough money to owe
the IRS so if you already get a refund
you don't qualify for the credit they're
wrong my husband is a disabled veteran
we don't have tax liability they know I
was a disabled veteran do they ask you
whether you have a taxable income no
none whatsoever so let's tax credit
pitch really only helps out High income
earners but hey at least your property's
value increased rights well not really
the only way solar panels increase your
property value is if you bought the
panels upfront in cash instead of taking
out a loan and even then the increase in
property value you do gets is not going
to be as much as what you pay for them
in the first place solar panels are
great for long-term savings they're an
investment but please take it from a
real estate professional they do not add
value to your home equal to their cost
most of the time and if you lease the
solar panels it actually damages your
property value does a solar lease
increase your home's value no it does
not you do not own the solar panels you
are merely purchasing your electricity
from the company leasing them to you it
might even hurt your home's value but if
you thought that wasn't enough it
actually gets a lot worse
[Music]
once your victims do sign on the dotted
line then they're gonna have to wait a
long time before the panels get
installed or even turn on and they might
already be making loan payments before
that even happens and when the panels
are installed it's often done
incorrectly due to just plain old
incompetence things like panels facing
north in the state with low sunshine
or for no obvious reason the panels
might not end up working at all only six
of his 18 solar panels work it has more
than a few horror stories of panels even
Catching Fire so of course your victims
are gonna get angry about this they're
gonna demand answers but unfortunately
for lung they're only going to be met
with bad customer service with no
answers and no help I am frustrated and
I want answers she's like it's your
fault if you're getting an electric bill
and if they try to break your contracts
you've got some fun little surprises
waiting for them called Power purchase
agreements which means if your victims
try to leave they'll have to pay massive
amounts of money and there's usually a
lot of fine print that makes the company
immune from being sued and that ladies
and gentlemen is why solar is one of the
fastest growing Industries out there
these companies are making 11 billion
dollars a year even smaller solar
companies are expected to make one to
two million dollars a year after just a
couple years of being in business with
the biggest companies in the space like
sun power corporate First Solar are each
worth two to three billion dollars each
but perhaps our favorite example of this
is power home solar and there their CEO
Jason Waller power home solar made
nearly 600 million dollars last year
using all these same sketchy tactics
that we discussed in this video that's
why Jason over here was able to pay
himself a one million dollar salary
while spending another 700 000 of
company money on business expenses what
kind of business expenses things like
leasing luxury cars on the company's
dime or hooking his family members up
with their own six-figure incomes and
luxury cars but here's the thing power
home solar is just a small tiny fish in
a giant Pond of other home solar
companies all scoring over average
Americans but now many customers are
starting to band together to fight back
a lot of people are filing class action
lawsuits in several States but
unfortunately getting any of them to
stick is still difficult there are
thousands of companies out there running
these schemes when new ones popping up
all the time they get up and running so
I know a bunch of people then they get
overrun with lawsuits and then file for
bankruptcy only to rename Rebrand and
then pop up against somewhere else that
power home solar one of the largest and
fastest growing energy companies is
rebranding itself as pink energy at this
point state attorney generals across the
country are stepping in telling loan
companies to stand down to stop
requiring payments from people who have
fallen for this fraud
[Music]
foreign
with all of this in mind it's important
to remember that this is not a knock on
solar energy itself whatever your
opinions on climate change are fossil
fuels will eventually run out we will
need to switch to Renewables in some
form or another the key is doing this in
a way that doesn't end up screwing
people over so the most important thing
you can do is stay informed there's a
ton of information out there about home
solar energy how the process works what
strategies are the most cost effective
how well solar panels work in your
region and the real benefits your state
and local government offer to make going
solar more affordable check those out if
you're interested stay dangerous and
we'll see you in the next one
thank you
[Music]